today on the matt walsh show as violent
crime surges to record levels across the
country the new d.a of manhattan has
decided to pour gasoline on the flames
he's announced this week that um he will
not prosecute armed robbery among a slew
of other serious crimes why are these
people doing this are they trying to
destroy their cities and if so why we'll
talk about that today also joe biden
addresses the nation about omnicorn and
lies repeatedly what else is new and
we're only one day away from the sacred
anniversary of january 6th how will you
commemorate the special occasion plus a
prominent trans youtuber apparently does
not approve of my best-selling lgbt
children's book johnny the walrus and
recorded a lengthy video explaining why
i'll respond to that today all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
a lower mortgage rate can make quite a
difference on your budget that's true
you could be saving hundreds of dollars
a month simply by refinancing to one of
these incredibly low rates think of how
much that can help then pick up the
phone and call american financing and do
it now before rates get any higher i
mean it you cannot miss out on what's
available right now especially since
there's no cost to get started we get a
free no obligation mortgage review from
a salary based mortgage consultant
someone who will walk you through custom
loan options finding every way possible
to save you up to a thousand dollars a
month without resetting your term you
could choose any term 10 years and over
and you have the potential to skip two
mortgage payments so don't put your refi
off any longer all you got to do is call
866-569-4711
that's 866-569-4711
i'll tell you one more time that's
866-569-4711
again
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net americanfinancing
nmls
18234 nmls consumeraccess.org
well for several years now billionaire
supervillain vampire george soros has
been quietly pumping many millions of
dollars into local district attorney
races all across the country now i
haven't checked his wikipedia but i'm
pretty sure that george soros is about
285 years old at this point old enough
to be joe biden's uncle you know and
he's only has about probably about a
century left to live then
yet he's decided to dedicate these
waning moments of his life to building
an army of rabidly left-wing das who are
all singularly singularly committed to
not doing the one single thing their job
requires them to do which is prosecute
crimes that's what they they're
prosecutors that's what they're supposed
to do
thanks to soros we now have d.a kim fox
in chicago who recently refused to
prosecute a group of gang bangers who
shot each other in the middle of the
street also d.a george gascon in los
angeles who's overseen an enormous spike
in crime since taking over a year ago in
that city d.a larry krasner in
philadelphia who has presided over an
historic surge in the homicide rate in
fact a dozen cities in the united states
set new murder records this year largely
thanks to soros das
but we aren't supposed to notice the
soros connection
and if we do notice that we aren't
supposed to talk about it because soros
is jewish and therefore any criticism of
him or related to him or anything he
does is anti-semitic according to the
media
now needless to say this rule is not
applied equally across the board no rule
ever is
because if it was then any criticism of
say ben shapiro or his company the daily
wire or even the beloved children's
authors and his employee would also be
anti-semitic but shapiro doesn't count
for whatever reason perhaps because he
actually practices judaism whereas soros
is a secular atheist but in any case
the latest soros creature to be elected
to the district attorney's office of a
major city is alvin bragg
he's the new d.a of manhattan
and in a memo released to his staff
earlier this week
bragg made it clear that
you know he's been watching all the ways
that his fellow soros goblins have
destroyed their respective cities
and he's concerned that the work is not
being done quickly enough
and that's why bragg according to the
memo
will be stepping back from prosecuting
crime
almost all crime including violent crime
now new york is one of the cities that's
experienced a crime surge especially in
violent crime with 485 murders committed
in the city in 2021 that's a jump of
well over 50 percent over the murder
rate just two years ago
but bragg says that those are rookie
numbers we got to pump them up
and here's how he plans to do it as
reported by the new york post listen to
this
in his first memo to staff on monday
alvin bragg said that his office will
not seek a carceral sentence that is a
prison sentence
except with homicides and a handful of
other cases including domestic violence
felonies some sex crimes and public
corruption
this rule may be accepted only in
extraordinary circumstances based on a
holistic analysis of the facts criminal
history victims input especially in
cases of violence or trauma and any
other information available the memo
reads
assistant district attorneys must also
now keep in mind the quote impacts of
incarceration including whether it
really does increase public safety
potential future barriers to convicts
include involving housing and employment
and the financial cost of prison and
also the racial disparities over who
gets time brag instructed
well at least they'll still be seeking
prison time
for some sex crimes
only some you know just the bad ones i
guess
so far this all sounds relatively in
line with the brand of lunacy we've
grown accustomed to over the last few
years
but it gets worse from the post it says
bragg's memo also detailed the following
instructions for prosecutors to reduce
charges filed by cops in various cases
armed robbers who use guns or other
deadly weapons to stick up stores and
other businesses will be prosecuted only
for petty larceny a misdemeanor
provided no victims were seriously
injured and there's no quote genuine
risk of physical harm to anyone
armed robbery a class b felony would
typically be punishable by a maximum of
25 years in prison while petty larceny
subjects offenders to up to 364 days in
jail and a 1 000 fine
so you heard that right
armed robbery
is a misdemeanor in new york now no
prison time
the memo goes on to explain that of
course such trivial crimes as burglary
and drug dealing will also be
effectively ignored
but the inclusion of armed robbery takes
this to a to a new level
the rationale seems to be that armed
robbery does not necessarily create a
quote genuine risk of physical harm
now silly me i would have thought that
there's always a genuine risk of
physical harm
when somebody points a gun at your face
but that's not what a risk of physical
harm looks like apparently you know a
guy who walks to his table at olive
garden without a mask on
now there's someone who's creating a
risk of physical harm
but if you were to merely take out a
firearm pointed in the direction of
somebody's skull and politely request
that the contents of the person's wallet
be emptied into the bag he's holding
well there's no reason to overreact to
that
after all what is it that armed robbers
almost always say at least in the movies
they you know they always say oh give me
your money and you won't get hurt do as
i say and you won't get hurt
so really if you if you do become
physically harmed during the course of
an armed robbery it's actually your
fault
you should have just done as you were
told i mean he said do what you're told
and you won't get hurt
i wish that everything that i'm saying
right now was a joke but it's not
here is i think one important point to
take away from all this
as much as as the people behind these
policies talk about systemic racism
and the impact of incarceration
and rehabilitation all the rest of it
none of that has anything to do with the
policies themselves
it is not an overabundance of compassion
that drives this
this is not a case of misplaced
sympathies
the bleeding heart liberal stereotype
was never accurate and certainly isn't
today
i'll tell you what actually drives this
actually it's two things
both are cynical and calculated one is
more politically practical than the
other
so the first is simply that this is an
attempt to solve the crime problem on
paper through reclassification
because if you stop treating crime as
crime then the crime goes away it's like
magic
sure there are just as many people
selling drugs and robbing liquor stores
in fact quite a bit more people now
because they're not prosecuting it but
that's only technically a crime problem
if you call it a crime
stop calling it a crime and the crime
goes away
leftist political leaders and da's are
to some extent
sort of adopting the rationalization of
a cuckolded husband who solves the
problem of his wife cheating on him by
deciding that well actually we're in an
open marriage
see it isn't adultery if he approves of
it he thinks
we'll just take this thing and we'll
recategorize it and uh and problem
solved
just as crime isn't crime if the people
in charge of prosecuting it are giving
it the thumbs up
that's the practical and the political
motivation
but i think at a deeper level there's
something else going on
this is at bottom
nothing less than an attempt to overturn
human society
to flip the moral order on its head
the anarchy in the streets is all a part
of the plan part of the design
the refusal to prosecute or punish
violent criminals who prey upon the weak
and vulnerable
is a direct affront to civilization
itself
because it flies in the face of every
value we hold dear as human beings
it is anti-human it's anti-civilization
it's anti-moral amoral
there's the real plan
to tear everything down leftism is
inherently destructive it's the only
thing it knows how to do
tear everything down
and then build something new something
hideous from the wreckage that's the
objective
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you're thinking about your
new year's resolutions this year here's
a resolution that you should make if you
haven't made it already which is to stop
wasting all of these many precious hours
at auto parts stores because if you need
auto parts all you got to do is go to
rockauto.com with the ever increasing
number of cars and models and makes and
everything that are that are out there
these days it's really hard to go to a
traditional stage chain storefront and
expect that they're going to have what
you need why waste your time when you
could just get everything you need and a
few clicks delivered directly to your
door by using rockauto.com rockauto.com
is a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything you
need from engine control modules and
brake parts to tail lamps motor oil even
new carpet whatever you need they have
it and the thing is rockauto.com the
catalog is unique it's very easy to
navigate and you could quickly see all
the parts that are available for your
vehicle choose the brands the
specifications the prices you prefer
that make it very easy for you best of
all all the prices are low for everybody
doesn't matter if you're a
do-it-yourselfer professional whatever
it is so go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and write walsh in there how
did you hear how did you hear about us
box so they know that we sent you uh i
hope you're bracing yourself by the way
if you live uh you know around
where we live here in tennessee uh
they're calling for another big winter
blast
tomorrow
and uh what they're saying is i could be
a little bit of ice and then maybe one
or two inches of snow
and uh you know maybe even up to three
inches of snow
but the thing is what i from what i
learned last year
living in the south for the first time
through my my first winter in the south
is what i've learned is that that you
really do have to treat that as the
apocalypse because that's how people
respond to it
i don't know what it is
around here but the the moment one flake
of snow just drifts down from the sky
from the clouds
all the drivers on the road they see
that and they just immediately turn
their wheels and run into the nearest
guard rail i don't know why
um total panic ensues
and the roads are not usable and the
funny thing is that everybody around
here drives pickup trucks
but then but then as soon as the weather
conditions
actually call for a vehicle of that type
like now now it's game time you have
this pickup truck i have one too
um and uh and as soon as the weather
it's like this this is this is what you
have this vehicle for
but everybody freaks out and panics um
and uh so you gotta you gotta prepare
yourself i was talking to my wife about
this earlier today and uh
she was saying oh do we know do we need
to go get salt or whatever and i said
don't worry about that the the main
thing we need are our sleds we got to
make sure we have sleds you know for the
kids and she said well we're good we
have four sleds you know one for each
kid
and i said
what about me
so she's running out right now to give
me a sled as well
um
my wife she keeps she keeps trying to
convince me as an adult that like well
why don't we take up skiing or some sort
of adult hobby i don't do that i but i
do like to sled just give me one of
those cheap five dollar saucer things
and i'll get on that and all i'll i'll
be out playing in the snow
for an hour after my kids go in
all right let's start with this uh biden
addressed the nation about the omnicorn
again yesterday
and he of course blatantly lied over and
over again i think this was the most
egregious lie that they're sticking with
even though everybody knows that this is
not true
it's 100 clear that it's not true but he
says this this is still a pandemic of
the unvaccinated listen
we have in hand all the vaccines we need
to get every american fully vaccinated
including the booster shot
so there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
so we've got to make more progress
and for patients who still haven't
gotten your kids vaccinated please get
them vaccinated
look out for their interest here it's
the best way to protect them
and for parents with kids too young to
be vaccinated
surround your kids with people who are
vaccinated
and make sure you're masking in public
so you don't get covert and give it to
your kids
surround your kids with people who are
vaccinated like uh i guess like a force
field
um
you know you know it actually the the
healthiest thing for your kid in fact
is um for them to have a bunch of other
kids around them that they can play with
and socialize with
uh not not not to be surrounded by an
army a force field of vaccinated people
but what he's saying here is of course
completely wrong
um
and he knows it too
and everybody knows it but this is this
is what they do they just stick
come up with a lie and stick with it and
keep saying it and keep saying it until
you break down people's defenses
and um kind of you have your own sort of
breakthrough case and then people start
believing what they what they originally
knew was a lie
everybody is getting
coveted especially omnicorn
i know this is this is anecdotal but
everybody this is all anyone anyone has
done this entire time let's talk about
their anecdotal experiences so i'll tell
you about my anecdotal experience which
i think is a little bit beyond anecdotal
because this when you when you look at
the data it appears to line up with data
so in my anecdotal experience over the
last two weeks um
almost like everyone i know has gotten
coveted and we can assume that it's
omnicorn because that's the dominant
traits that everybody's getting and it's
so contagious that you know if you just
walk by someone you're probably gonna
get it uh apparently and it's and it's
fine because it's tot it's mild and it's
a cold but
um
everyone around me is getting it
and in my family we'd all been feeling
you know kind of kind of special because
up to this point none of us had ever got
in my immediate family and also in the
extended family no one had gotten sick
over two years and then everyone gets it
but what i can also tell you is that i
got a pretty good mix in my family of
people who are
vaccinated and unvaccinated
not boosted i don't know i actually do
not know a single person who's gotten
the booster shot
but we've got vaccinated unvaccinated
people and um
everyone's experience with omnicorn was
almost exactly the same
regardless of vaccination status
i'm not saying that's gonna be the case
for everybody youtube i'm just telling
you what my experience was
everyone's
encounter with omnicorn almost exactly
the same
you know
feel like you're coming down with
something
mildly too moderately sick
for me it was a little bit it was worse
than a mild i wouldn't call it a mild
cold i call it a moderate cold
for a couple of days and then you start
getting better and you're fine
and i look at my own family people i
know it's it
and you if you were to to look at their
experience
with covid
you wouldn't be able to guess based on
that whether they're vaccinated or not
and then when you take a look at the
data
that appears to line up
that everybody's getting it and it's
mild for everybody but then what you of
course what you always hear so it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy
because every day you know we hear from
another person in media or politician or
some prominent person who says yeah i'm
i got just diagnosed positive for covet
but then what do they always tell you
they say i'm i'm vaxxed and boosted
and thank god because if i wasn't it
would be way worse
well how do you know that
maybe it would have been significantly
worse if you didn't have your three
shots or your four shots or whatever
but how do you know that
that's not based on anything
other than your own assumption your own
hope
and there's very good reason to think
that it would not have been
significantly worse if you weren't
vaccinated because
especially with this variant
it's mild for almost everybody
and if you're not in a high-risk group
and you're
you know relatively healthy and you're
not you're not morbidly obese
most likely
this was going to be a mild to moderate
situation regardless
all right we got one more clip from
biden um some more
more encouraging words for those of us
uh who are not vaccinated he says again
this is going to be a winter of sickness
and death for you listen
and by the way we have booster shots for
the whole nation okay
you can still get covet
but
it's highly unlikely very unlikely that
you become seriously ill and we're
seeing covet 19 cases among vaccinated
workplaces across america including here
at the white house but if you're
vaccinated and boosted you are highly
protected
you know
be concerned about omicron but don't be
alarmed
but if you're unvaccinated you have some
reason to be alarmed many of you will uh
you know uh uh
you'll experience severe illness many
cases if you get covet 19 if you're not
vaccinated
some will die needlessly die
be concerned but not alarmed unless
you're not vaccinated in which case
you're going to die
um
but which is it
you he just said that the pandemic this
is a pandemic of the unvaccinated and
then he follows that up by saying yeah i
mean people everyone everyone's getting
it even if they're vaccinated even here
in the white house
well then you just say it's a pandemic
of the unvaccinated which is it
are we all in this together or not
because it seems like whether we like
whether we like it or not we are
at least in terms of being susceptible
to contracting covet
all right in keeping with the uh the
theme of the week the media are
discovering truths about kobe that many
of us have known and have been shouting
from the rooftops
um or maybe shouting at a brick wall it
felt like for nearly three years now
david leonhardt over at the new york
times has a piece titled
no way to grow up for the past two years
americans have accepted more harm to
children in exchange for less harm to
adults
and it's a
it's a good piece and i recommend
reading it
it also sounds like someone i know
someone in someone in this very room in
fact
the room i'm sitting in right now
has been saying for years that the worst
thing about our coveted policies as they
pertain to children
is that all of it is being done
not to protect kids but to protect
adults
the new york times has discovered this
three years later but if you've been
listening to this show you've heard it
almost every day for three years
because that has always been apparent
and it's been grotesque from the
beginning
you know it's one thing i would have a
lot more tolerance i have a lot more
tolerance and patience
for people who go overboard
in trying to protect their kids
as pa i i understand that instinct as a
parent
we're all guilty of it to some extent
um
you know there are there are there at
least going to be certain areas in life
certain areas that play on your own
special anxieties as a parent where you
give your children where you're much
more restrictive of your children than
you need to be but just because you're
worried about them
even if the fear is mostly irrational
so i get that and you know something if
this was first of all
if if this was a virus that's that
specially affected children
if it if it um attacked and victimized
children in the way that it attacks and
victimizes elderly people of the
morbidly obese
then
probably
my opinion about our response to it
would have been totally different
in fact i probably would have been
sitting sitting here saying let's shut
society down for the sake of the kids
because at that point for the sake of
protecting kids who cannot protect
themselves and as society that i believe
that should be our number one priority
is to protect the next generation
as parents for our own kids that's our
number one job
and so then you're then you start
thinking well like any sacrifice i have
to make is worth it
but that wasn't the case thank god
but even if uh you know if if if covid
was a little bit more dangerous to kids
and so we saw many of these policies
being put in place
um
out of a concern for the kids themselves
i wouldn't have agreed with it
trying to do remote learning for three
years
which is impossible for kids
because they're not gonna learn that way
you can't put a six-year-old in front of
a in front of a computer screen for six
hours a day and expect them to learn
anything so i wouldn't have agreed with
it but i would have been more
sympathetic to it
but that's not what's happening
we're doing all of this to protect the
adults
that's always been the case
when you see all of the videos
of uh
you know three-year-old kids on
airplanes
who are being yelled at to put masks on
and that eventually kicked off the plane
while they're crying and confused
because they don't want to wear this
stupid thing on their face
it's impossible to make a kid that young
wear anything above their neck
um and when you see all of that these
are not and you see the adults
kicking a kid off the plate they're
they're not doing it out of a desperate
concern for the child's safety they're
doing it out of a desperate and selfish
concern for their own safety and not
even their own safety it's not even that
they're protecting themselves that would
be bad enough
but they're not protecting themselves
physically because that child presents
almost no threat to them physically
it's about protecting the adults
feelings their their their sense of
security it's about making them feel
better
so we're gonna ruin kids lives
we're gonna ruin their their social and
emotional and psychological development
keep them isolated
deprive them of a real education not
that they get much of a real education
in school anyway
put masks on them do all of this scare
them to death
um
so that we can feel better
feel better
so
that's a speech i i'm i'm now rehearsing
the speech you've heard 10 000 times and
now
we're we're hearing it from the new york
times so i want to read a little bit of
this because it is it is actually worth
reading
uh even if it's annoying that it took
this long to get to it uh but there is a
lot of useful information here
so here's what he writes in part he says
american children are starting 2022 in
crisis i have long been aware the
pandemic was upending children's lives
but until i spent time pulling together
data and reading reports i did not
understand just how alarming the
situation had become
well you might have understood david if
you'd listened to us we were trying to
tell you
um for the past you know 36 months or
whatever
children and then it goes into what what
the exact toll is children fell far
behind in school during the first year
of the pandemic and have not caught up
among third through eighth graders math
and reading levels were all lower than
normal this fall according to the nwea a
research group
not to be confused with the nwa the
shortfalls were largest to black and
hispanic students as well as students in
schools with high poverty rates michael
patrilli of the thomas b fordham
institute says we haven't seen this kind
of academic achievement crisis in living
memory many children and teenagers are
experiencing
mental health problems aggravated by the
isolation and disruption of the pandemic
three medical groups including the
american academy pediatrics recently
declared a national state of emergency
in children's mental health
they cited dramatic increases in
emergency department visits for all
mental health emergencies
suicide attempts have risen slightly uh
have risen slightly among adolescent
boys and sharply among adolescent girls
the number of er visits for suspected
suicide attempts by 12 to 17 year old
girls rose by 51
from early 2019 to early 2021 why would
it affect girls even more than boys i
mean it's affecting both groups
but girls are also more relational by
nature
um
and so they're going to
naturally be more affected when you take
those relationships away from them i
think that's probably the reason
gun violence among against children has
increased as part of a broader
nationwide rise in crime in chicago for
example 101 residents under age 20 were
murdered last year
um and then um
goes on with some of the more some more
academic problems and then and then so
on so
children are
being the victims of uh the victims of
violence more than ever suicide attempts
to have a 51 percent increase in suicide
attempts is
it's staggering catastrophic
and
victims of violence from other people
all of this is happening
leaving aside
again the fact that that that we've all
been saying this
or many of us have been saying this for
a long time the other problem is that
even in these these articles where
members of the media are seeming to
finally confront what we've done to kids
it's still not a full confrontation
they're still ignoring
huge pieces of the puzzle
like for example he's still not
confronting the fact that um
masking
you know the psychological toll of
forcing kids to wear masks for three
years
he's not talking about that
that's a that's a big part of this
especially again when we talk about the
psychological effects that this has had
no generation in
the history of the world has ever had
had this
i mean there are some kids today who are
six years old or seven years old and
they don't remember a time when they
didn't have to wear a mask when they
left their house
that's there's never been a generation
of kids that's experienced that
sure there have been kids who at various
points have had to wear medical masks
but as a lifestyle as an everyday
all-day thing for years on end
no
um but the media is still not that
that's that is one line that the media
is not ready to cross in fact as far as
that goes as far as masking kids goes
it's only getting worse here's a today
show segment from yesterday advocating
now n95s
for kids
they go all the way over your head not
the most comfortable but very very snug
not a lot of air is getting in between
the sides of my cheeks or the tops of my
cheeks hey vic the kids are back in the
classroom at least the overwhelming
majority of them um what's what's the
recommendation for our youngest learners
okay so we talked to dr john torres
about this because i actually just sent
my kids out the door this morning
minutes ago with two masks he says
obviously the can 95 and 95 are the most
effective but it can be really hard to
find them in small kid sizes and also to
keep them on your kids all day they're
not the most comfortable so the second
best option is to make sure you have a
kid-sized surgical mask and by the way
look at what a difference the kids size
mask is from the adult size so you
really want to make sure you have one
that fits your child's face
and you want to layer the cloth mask
over that mask so the surgical mask goes
on first
and then the cloth mask if you can't do
that surgical mask alone dr torres says
least best but better than nothing the
two-layer cotton mask that fits your
child the best match certainly is the
one that your child will wear and keep
on the whole day when they're in the
classroom
yeah put the n95 because as she says no
air is getting in
and that's
that's great for kids right i mean who
needs to breathe air
it's a good thing our kids are all um
you know
marine creatures they're all they're all
deep sea creatures they they don't need
to breathe air
i i've got a better recommendation for
all your masks because you take all this
you've got all the examples of the
different masks there so here's my
here's my uh personal recommendation you
take those masks
um along with like we talked about
yesterday along with the tests that you
have you've been hoarding you take all
of that
and uh throw it in the garbage
and stop abusing your children your
psychopaths
all right we are now
one day away from the sacred anniversary
of january 6th hopefully you've you've
thought about what you will do to
commemorate the day
um i can tell you i've talked about this
with my wife a little bit but uh it and
i think what we're going to be doing is
we're going to rise early in the morning
and then we're going to sit around on on
the floor
in what we call a cry circle and you
know what a christ circle is every
family you guys do this where we sit in
a circle we just cry silently for two
hours
um fully masked obviously and then we're
gonna take turns reciting our favorite
passages from uh amanda gorman poems or
from aoc's instagram live transcripts
you could do either one and then
obviously we'll sacrifice a goat to our
idol of saint george floyd um that's
kind of our own tradition but each
family has their own
the new york times and the media of
course they've got their traditions for
january 6. they have yet another january
6 reflection piece this one titled the
capitol police and the scars of january
6th
for many officers their bodies minds and
lives will never be the same after the
attack
you read that you think well will we
ever see an article like that about the
officers who suffered
through the blm riots for example
what about their bodies and minds and
lives
and the thing about the officers who are
in the blm rides is that uh
not only were those riots far more
violent
and far more dangerous
but after the fact and during these
officers did not have the entire
american media
supporting them
so they had the
the insult to injury here
where they were being portrayed as the
villains by the media
at least the capitol police officers
have you know are are being celebrated
by the media
maybe that'll help heal their their
wounds a little bit uh the the other
officers
who dealt with blm riots quite the
opposite
here's
but all joking aside for a second when
it comes to january 6th
here's what that was
if we need to reflect on it which i
don't think we do because more than
enough has has been said
but here's what january 6 was in reality
it was very very stupid
okay the rioters were very stupid
they acted emotionally
they had no plan beyond that
that's one of the ways that we knows
that no this was not this was not an
insurrection
there was no plan in place to overthrow
the government
this was very stupid these were
emotional people who were
just acting out and doing whatever and
that's why you can you can look at
the the ample amount of security footage
that we've seen from inside the capitol
and what do you see you see all these
people rush in and then once they get
inside they just kind of start
moseying around and then they eventually
leave
and a couple of them take some souvenirs
with them
it's kind of like a dark knight the
joker talks about he's like a dog
chasing a car he wouldn't know what to
do once he catches it so these rioters
they got into the capitol building
didn't know what to do once they got
there because there was no plan
but it's very very stupid
and uh counterproductive in the extreme
let's say
but they were not insurrectionists
because again they never posed the
slightest threat to our system of
government
they were not they were not going to
overthrow the government
how exactly was that going to work
i mean for everybody in the media tells
us our system is on the was on the brink
it was almost toppled over that day how
even in your wildest fantasies
what could have happened that would have
resulted in our government being
overthrown
this is a very stupid event that has
provided um lots of ammunition from the
media and that's all that really needs
to be said about it
in a healthy country would have long
since moved on by now
but the media and the government the
democrat party they're not going to
allow that to happen
january 6th gave them ammunition that
they will never stop using ever
and that's another one of the reasons
why this was a very stupid thing
all right uh so i've had this
in the uh on deck for a few days now i
got to finally mention it you've
probably heard about it by now this is
from the daily wire the most successful
female quote unquote ever to appear on
jeopardy is actually a biological male
amy schneider the show's first
transgender contestant became the
highest earning contestant who
identifies as female after winning for
the 18th consecutive time last friday
um i guess his winnings are probably
higher now but schneider has now won
seven hundred and six thousand dollars
on the game show with a chance to win
more tonight um
yeah so this is a few days old i'm not
sure if amy schneider is still kicking
ass on jeopardy or not but the the
highest earning woman
in jeopardy history is a man
here's a good morning america a few days
ago gushing over this whole story
we're going to turn to a story that's a
little bit more uplifting hopefully uh
jeopardy champion amy schneider in a
league of her own now this morning she
won for the 21st straight time on
wednesday the most by a woman just days
after taking the record for highest
all-time earnings for a woman earlier
this year this year schneider she made
history as the first transgender
contestant to make the tournament of
champions she still has a long way to go
though to catch host ken jennings and
his 74-game winning streak but it has
been fun to watch she's well on her way
who run the world girls
there you go
do they though because
the top female jeopardy contestant is a
man
and the top female college swimmer is a
man
and the first
female
four-star admiral in the public health
service is a man
and some of the top female mma
fighters have been men
and some of the top female track high
school track athletes have all been men
so do girls run the world
girls don't even run
female track anymore
um
if if if this
if it wasn't for the fact that our
civilization was uh was being was being
fundamentally deconstructed you would
have to you would have to laugh about
this because the patriarchy has won
you know the patriarchy was was on the
ropes a little bit for a few decades
really
and uh and then and then they they kind
of you know
regrouped and and thought about it
and then realized
that no if the patriarchy is going to
win it has to be has to be this has to
be infiltration the patriarch has
infiltrated the female ranks
and achieved ultimate victory it's kind
of inspiring
in a certain way
let's get now to our uh comment section
[Music]
so joshua says usually i agree with you
matt on the over diagnosis of mental
disorders but the antonio brown case is
different i recommend you watch the film
concussion there's a trend of nfl
players acting irrationally and
violently this is seen in many contact
sports where there's consistent brain
trauma like boxing and football
but not in sports like basketball and
baseball where there's little brain
injury ct is a very real thing but we
can only tell if someone hasn't after
they die it's very possible that antonio
brown has cte and i think it's fair for
his possible mental health issues to be
discussed this case is different from a
simone biles or a naomi osaka
okay well
again as i said yesterday and i don't
claim to be an expert on this i don't
think you are either um in fact there's
really nobody is fully an expert on cte
because it's very very it's it's
mysterious right now there's still a lot
that is not known about it
and whether or not even the basic
question of whether or not cte is
directly caused by football injuries
that is far from confirmed
and then once you confirm that
to to explain how a brain injury could
cause
behavior
um that is also going to be very
difficult to explain
so there are a lot of unknown pieces
and yet with all of these unknowns
people who don't know antonio brown have
never looked at his brain have never
looked at a brain scan
haven't been able to open up his head
and take a look at it because as you
said you can't do that until the
person's dead anyway yeah
you feel like you can sit back and and
diagnose him not only diagnose him with
this condition
but directly link certain behaviors to
that condition
that you that you assume he has
it's to me it's so self-evidently absurd
that it just seems like you're you're
trying desperately to make excuses for
this for someone who's a total
and has been his whole life
his whole career has always been this
way
and for some reason it's like you you
want to make excuses rather than
what why don't we go when you're
when you have a situation and there are
several different potential competing
explanations
okay it's occam's razor you go with the
simplest explanation the explanation
that requires the fewest number of
assumptions
and to blame it on cte requires an
enormous array of assumptions
whereas you could just say he's a jerk
he's an entitled jerk
like so many before him especially in
sports and that's it
okay just ray says there's a testing
center near where i live and every day
it's jam-packed with idiotic sheep
literally
impeding traffic on a daily basis my
lord i think i've seen some of the same
cars parked days on end
live your lives people the only reason
this has gone on three years is because
you allow it to well no i mean look
you've got to wait in line for three
hours to find out if you're sick or not
if you wake up with a fever and a cough
or something you're not feeling well
well you know i don't know i could be
sick but let me go wait in line for
three hours to find out you say sheep
speaking of which i almost forgot this i
got to show you this i mean as as you
mentioned you say that these are all
sheep
um
there's uh do we have this from
let's pull the tweet up from cbs
we don't have the tweet okay well some
farmer i think it's a farmer in scotland
i'm just going to assume uh on you know
making making uh
prejudicial assumptions here he's a
farmer in scotland he uh want i think
wants to send a pro-vaccine message so
he could play this
he
got all his sheep together
and he had them
and i guess he lured them into place
with food and then
he had them all form the shape of a
syringe
and this is supposed to be a pro-vaccine
message
sheep
forming the shape of a syringe
i don't think that sends the message you
want it to it does send a powerful
message
perhaps a true one but not the one you
want all right let's go back to the
comments
um
thin blue
thin blue pines says 100 that earring
note was planted you have a daughter
mastermind on your hands i suffer from
the same empathetic response to my
kiddos
silently bummed out about being told no
uh
yeah she
i know that my daughter has figured
these things out fortunately my sons
have not
my daughter's figured out some of the
manipulation techniques
my sons are a little bit slower on the
uptake when it comes to those things i
think that's pretty pretty common with
with boys
and so they still think if they want
something from me they'll just they'll
just whine or yell or whatever and it's
it's not doing it fellas not gonna do it
um
let's see
sam says i have to say while i don't
like the spider-man movies plot which
was riddled with plot holes i don't
think you could properly judge an mcu
movie if you have if you've only seen
one
if you want to be a critic of it find
time to actually watch more of the
movies try to understand the broader
story if you haven't seen doctor
strange's movies why should you be able
to condemn his character because it's a
very stupid character
that's why that's how i condemn it and
it seems like you haven't seen
spider-man 2 the original because you
had if you had you might understand how
doc ock turned good really i would have
understood that so the kid in a
laboratory takes some scrap metal and a
couple of uh you know
like a couple of spoons or whatever and
just ties it all together puts it on the
back of his head and he turns good
magically i would have understood that
um
again
spoilers on this movie but i just want
to highlight
i've given you the warning for this the
spider-man movie that everybody's raving
about
what they do in this film i was actually
i was expecting it to be bad because all
of the marvel movies are bad
all of them there has not been a good
one
um they're not just bad but they're all
an affront to cinema they are
anti-cinema
but this was way worse than i than i
could have ever imagined it would be
like my worst nightmare but worse than
that
because what they did with this movie is
that you've got 20 years of spider-man
villains
and each movie right for the last two
years has been sent sometimes multiple
movies centered around one of these
villains
and spider-man's fighting the villains
and trying to defeat them and then and
then finally at the end spider-man
defeats the villain and then we say well
that's that's the end of that story okay
and in this film because they're just
desperate for a story
they say you know what let's bring all
of those villains back
and then have spider-man magically make
them all not bad anymore
do you think okay two things number one
why didn't he do that to begin with if
that's an option if it's an option to
just make something and put it on the
guy's neck and make him good
well we could we could have avoided 20
years of bad movies have you just done
that to begin with
but also you've completely erased all of
the stories that came before it
you've just negated them
which those stories don't mean anything
to me but if i was a fan of spider-man
because i'm a 12 year old boy you're the
only ones who should be fans of these
movies uh i'd be pretty annoyed by that
and then also one other thing because we
have to move on
this this whole the whole the whole uh
catalyst of the plot is that
if i remember correctly because it's all
pretty incomprehensible and incoherent
but uh a villain from a previous movie
who apparently could have just been
turned good
uh with a with a couple of spoons and
toothpicks but they never thought to do
it so the villain in the previous movie
told the world that um
peter parker's spider-man
and
peter parker in this and that was the
end of the last one this movie peter
parker is upset because it's making his
life inconvenient that everyone knows
that he's spiderman and so he goes to
the wizard this wizard guy benedict
cumberbatch guy and says can you erase
from the entire world's memory the fact
that i'm spider-man
and then the wizard says well i can but
then i'm gonna have to erase the memory
of you as peter parker that's the only
way that this magic spell works
and then things go wrong and haywire and
then and then and then eventually at the
end they he ends up erasing everyone's
mind anyway but well how about this
instead
if this is an option
go to the wizard and have the wizard
erase everyone's memory of the bad guy
who told people this information to
begin with
why not erase their memory of him
instead of you
well because that would end the movie in
three minutes
okay
i think that's about enough of that
as you know the daily wire has led the
charge to sue the bite administration
for his vaccine mandates and now we're
taking it all the way to the supreme
court this friday the supreme court will
convene to hear arguments on the
legality and constitutionality of the
mandate which means that this week is
going to be huge in our fight against
medical tyranny we have over one million
signatures on our do not comply petition
currently but it's vital that it
increases before friday so help us send
our message loud and clear and head to
dailywire.com do not comply right now
we're counting on you to help us put a
stop to this absolutely disgusting and
tyrannical federal overreach now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to be canceling
samantha lux who is a youtuber and quote
trans woman that is a biological male
with a youtube channel actually a quite
popular channel with well over 600 000
subscribers somehow sam has many videos
promoting transgenderism and quite often
responding to perceived instances of
transphobia
one of the most recent videos on the
channel targets if you can believe it
none other than the leading lgbt
children's author on the planet yours
truly
sam stumbled across my children's book
johnny the walrus which is still
available for pre-order over at
johnnywalrus.com by the way and uh and
uh does not approve
specifically my video where i read the
book to a group of children has provoked
sam's ire in a video titled transphobes
are writing children's books trans girl
reacts
this is good you know i am sincerely
interested to hear how a trans girl
quote unquote reacts to johnny the
walrus perhaps this will be a
point-by-point rebuttal perhaps evidence
and science and logic and bulletproof
moral arguments will all be marshaled
and by the end of the video i will have
completely changed my mind
realize the error in my ways repented of
my anti-trans beliefs
maybe even because of this video that
we'll watch together i will become trans
myself
it's possible
so let's watch some of this and see what
our friend samantha lux brings to the
table
now if you're familiar with the content
that i create here on my channel if
you're familiar with the arguments that
conservatives love to make about trans
people you would be familiar with
transphobes claim that we are
indoctrinating their children that were
making their children gay that were
forcing their young tomboy daughter to
become a boy that's not me who me who me
i would never i love you trans girl
i love your tomboy daughter she is great
what i don't love
is a hypocrite matt walsh if you are not
familiar with is
like an infamous transphobe on youtube
this
posted a video one week ago reading his
book johnny the walrus to a bunch of
little kids
okay so we're off to a rough start here
uh already a few points
first i do not believe sam that you are
forcing any child to do anything
or making any child or making any child
do anything
i am accusing you and your fellow
propagandists
of trying to heavily influence children
with falsehoods distortion lies and
other forms of insanity that they the
children do not have the mental capacity
to sort through so indoctrination does
not often involve physical force
because you cannot physically force
someone to believe something
belief requires mental assent not
physical ascent
but you can coerce and trick people into
believing things and when they're
children that's very easy to do
as you know from experience
also by the way i appreciate being
called infamous and i won't take any
issue with that label
but um i am not an infamous transphobe
because i'm not a transphobe at all
and when i say i'm not a transphobe i'm
not saying it to gain your approval or
to convince you that i'm not bigoted
yeah i couldn't give it less less of a
damn if you think that i'm a bigoted or
not it doesn't matter to me
i am instead concerned with definitions
and the definition of phobia is
irrational fear
i'm not afraid of trans people if i was
i wouldn't spend so much of my time
saying things that i know will make you
angry
my fear and it is not irrational
is of the effect that trans propaganda
has on society and especially on kids
okay so we have that clarified let's
continue we have to skip around a little
bit because sam's video is long and it
seems like a little too self-involved
even for me to spend too much time
reacting to somebody else reacting to
one of my videos but we'll watch enough
to get the gist and to discover whether
sam will be able to make any arguments
that will disprove or undermine my
central points let's keep going
all right do you understand the
comparison that's gonna be happening
here he's like this book is about a
little boy who thinks he's a walrus and
his mom you know
also is convinced that he's a real
walrus do you get the correlation it's
gonna be about a little boy that thinks
he's a girl or something and the mom is
convinced that he's a real girl how
creative how did you ever come up with
such a creative powerful analogy for
children
who don't understand what you're talking
about
yeah well you're right it's not creative
it's not creative at all i mean the
comparison between somebody identifying
as a different sex and someone
identified as an animal has been done a
million times i'm not the first to do it
south park did it a decade ago but the
problem is that nobody on your side has
ever come up with anything approaching
an effective response to the analogy
you've never been able to explain why
it's wrong
all you can do all you ever do is just
scoff that you've heard the point before
well we know you've heard it and you're
going to keep hearing it over and over
again until you answer it
all right let's continue
what is this thing doing on the floor
that's we don't have to worry about that
we're gonna read the book now this man
has never met a kid in his whole life
never interacted with one child he's
like i don't give a sit down we're gonna
read the book i'm here for half an hour
and then i gotta go so sit down so i can
film okay
thank you brat
no i think um i think the problem is
that you've never been around a dad
before which maybe i would have already
guessed
um i'm around kids all the time because
i have four of them but so i but i have
by now developed a critical case of dad
syndrome and that means that i'm just
snapping my fingers and i'm keeping
people on task that's what i do i'm dead
you should see me during short time
every night in my house you get over
there pick up those shoes you come over
vacuum the rug
i don't even remember anybody's names
anymore
that's another symptom of dad syndrome
okay uh skipping ahead
but johnny's mom's phone said it's not
just pretend
so she went on her phone and there are
people telling her that this isn't
pretend he's really a walrus
only a bigot would say that how dare you
offend what's a bigot anybody know
kids i don't even i don't know how all
these kids are i'm not good at
estimating age but they don't know what
you're talking about you don't see their
face did he run this past like an actual
children's author and we like read it to
a kid and see what they thought before
he published it i think he just went for
it of course they don't know what a
bigot is
they're for i mean it does make sense
that he would go for children because
you know they have the same capacity for
intellectual thought as him like babe if
you're gonna write a children's book
write it for children write it using
words that they understand and that they
know and that you don't have to explain
for them to understand what you're
trying to say through your book um first
of all don't call me babe second did i
run it by an actual children's author
yes i ran it by myself
and when myself came to myself and said
self what do you think of this
children's book idea my self-responded
self that's an exceptional idea
so i did get the go ahead from an expert
in the field of children's literature if
that matters to you now
sam also says that that some of these
concepts are above a child's head
yes sam
that's the point
now you're getting it if a silly story
about a kid transitioning into a walrus
is inevitably too weird and abstract for
children then what happens if we mix sex
and gender into it
does it suddenly become more appropriate
for children
if a child as you say isn't even old
enough to understand what a bigot is
or to hear the word
then is he old enough to be introduced
to a concept like transgenderism
if he can't understand bigots can he
understand what it means for a boy to
have a girl mystically trapped inside
him
if my book is above his head what about
a choice that will fundamentally change
his life and alter him physically and
biologically forever
is that above his head too
what do you think
connect the dots sam you can do it
you'll need to eat worms and to put on
gray makeup
the worms give you whiskers the gray
blends you in the doctor says
and a simple procedure cuts heat into
fins
the doctor wants to cut
into johnny and make him into a walrus
it's gross eating worms mom
they're all so dang twitchy he doesn't
want any worms our children
you see what he's doing here with the
analogies that he's drawing he's arguing
that parents are forcing their young
children to take medications that they
don't want to take or to have surgeries
that they don't want to take or to
transition when they don't want to
transition that's not what happens you
know children have a say in the process
children are allowed to
make their own decision of course with
the help of medical professionals of
course of course but like this whole
part that johnny's like i don't want to
eat worms that would be the end of it
that's the end of it jordan doesn't eat
worms no worms for johnny
no worms
i will say we got exactly the reaction
to the uh doctor page with the bone saw
that that i had in mind when we included
that page and i fought for that page now
there was i would say a little bit
behind the scenes there was some
discussion
um over here uh about that particular
page with the doctor with the bone bone
saw chasing the child and i fought for
that
i said that's got to be in there
and it was
no sam but you say children make their
own decision but but children can't make
their own decisions
if i'm arguing that a certain course of
action
is harmful for a child bad for them
damaging to them it does no good to
retort that the child wants to do it
children who want to do harmful things
should still be prevented from doing
those things
why because they're children
they don't understand what they're
saying they don't know what they want
and often they don't actually want what
they think they want
at red robin the other day my
five-year-old told me he wanted to order
salmon
for his first dinner now i knew damn
well that that kid did not want salmon
he wanted chicken tenders and fries
because that's what he always wants and
it's the only thing he'll ever actually
eat at a restaurant
so i didn't let him have the meal that
he wanted
because i knew that he didn't really
want it
because he's a kid
and that's just for something as
frivolous as a meal at red robin
what if your son says he wants to become
a girl
or a salmon for that matter
not only can you be sure that he doesn't
really want that because he doesn't
understand what he's saying or what it
means or what the implications are
because he can't because he's just a kid
but also in this case whereas it's at
least possible to actually order salmon
it's not possible for him to actually
become a girl
which is reason enough to not give him
what he says he wants
all right let's skip ahead again and see
if sam saves the best rebuttals for the
very end
what's the moral of the story what's the
lesson here aren't children's books
supposed to have like a lesson that's
you know clear because i don't know what
this is trying to say i don't know what
this lesson here is the other lesson is
don't listen to the creepy people in
your phone don't trust medical
professionals
walruses are mean like oh my goodness
maybe it's like a writing class or
something ask a kid like do you know
what this book is about
because none of them did like you could
argue that this book is made for adults
write a book for adults
write a book for adults or is it that
you have to dumb down these analogies
and these arguments for children brain
because they don't hold any weight in
actual adult language but yeah that is
it for this video what do you guys think
you're gonna go get johnny the walrus
the book
uh
well since you asked
what do i think i think you should
probably in the future have some kind of
rebuttal if you're going to make a
rebuttal video
you rebutted my points in the same way
that my dog rebuts the deer that he sees
running through the backyard by just
barking incoherently at them
yeah you're right that i did dumb down
the arguments and analogies but
apparently i wasn't able to make them
dumb enough for you to understand
my story about a kid pretending to be a
walrus was it would seem slightly above
your reading level
and that's a shame because it's a
message that you might have really
benefited from
and instead i'm forced to say finally
samantha lux
that you are sadly tragically cancelled
but everybody else can buy my book
johnny the walrus at johnnythewalrus.com
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
valdoski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
today on the ben shapiro show according
to the left the exceptions should get to
make all the rules on gender crime and
marriage plus the chicago's teachers
union decides it never go back to school
and joe biden addresses the nation on
the omicron surge that's today on the
benchmark show give it a listen